Instant is arguably the single strongest
word you can see on any magic card.
Turning trash into playable and mediocre
into staple. But on different cards,
this word hits differently. Let's make a
skill. Magic players love skills except
when we have to step onto one. We have
the storm skill, raaya skill, harden
skill, salt scores, brackets, and all
that. And today I'm here to introduce
the how much better does being instant
make this card in the format of
commander skill
for short. On the top end of the scale
is counter spells. Yes, a source three
counter spell would be approximately
100% worse. But what comes after gets
interesting. Just beneath counter spells
in my opinion lie removals. Yes, I
genuinely believe that spot removals are
maybe 80 to 90% worse at sorcery speed.
And I'm not exaggerating. Now take a
look at our clickbay thumbnail. It's
actually not a clickbait for once. Feed
the swarm currently in over 550,000
decks is terrible. The baseline here is
this. In Commander, you don't actually
have to beat your opponents directly.
You just have to outlast. And how do we
outlast? By making the best decisions,
managing our resources, and striking at
the right time. And Feed the Swarm
doesn't do any of that. Say you blow up
an opponent's creature with Feed the
Swarm. That's an okay play. Only if they
were planning to attack you. If not, you
just helped the other two opponents and
dropped your own life total to do it. In
this scenario, Feed the Swarm wasn't
zero value. It was negative. You were
closer to winning the game before you
cast it than after. Now, of course, you
can mitigate that somewhat with
politics, but even then, this isn't
nearly as flexible and open-ended as
instant speed alternatives. Think of how
much better instance are than sorceries
in regular 60 card format. Times that by
about 10,000, and that's the difference
in multiplayer. Also, yes, I get it.
Feed the swarm deals with enchantments,
but now we have withering torment. And
no, you don't need both. I mean,
otherwise, how did mono black players
survive before Duskort? Do you even need
to be able to answer every threat? Is
that even possible? But that's another
topic. Now, let's take a more immersive
example to really illustrate what I mean
by the importance of flexibility and
open-endedness. We're going to go a
little deeper. Let's look at Vindicate,
which is considered a solid removal due
to its flexibility. Far from its glory
days, but still sees play in plenty of
decks. But imagine an instant speed
Vindicate. Oh, wait. You don't have to.
Generous gift is pretty much that.
Imagine a game with four players. you
playing whatever black white deck,
player A on dragons, player B on
artifacts, and player C on some shifty
control deck. Imagine player A has a
wrathful red dragon, the best creature
on the board at the moment. You want to
kill it with Vindicate before it smacks
you. Doesn't seem like a terrible play,
but you don't have Vindicate. You have
generous gift, three open mana, and
patience. Pass the turn. On their first
main phase, player A drops a cavern
horde dragon. swings that at player B
because you know artifacts and the
wrathful red dragon unfortunately comes
at you. Now things have changed. The
dynamics are completely different. We
have to re-evaluate three lines. Do we
stop player A from connecting with the
cavern horde dragon and further develop
their board state or save ourselves from
the red dragon damage? Or we can just do
nothing and keep our options open and
see what happens. The decision here
depends on our life total, our cards in
hand and what our opponents have on
board. But whatever decision we make
now, it will be better and probably more
educated than vindicating the red dragon
at first. Now, let's say we decide to
let it all happen. Player A uses the
extra treasure to drop a dragon tempest
and passes the turn. Now, this is
getting scary. Player B untaps and plays
an oblivion stone,
threatening to wipe the board, but they
don't want to because they have some
decent artifacts as well. Player C plays
a land and passes, holding up their
mana. Now, I know at this point we're
turning into command zone, extra turns,
but at least our turns are scripted, so
you know it's quality. Now, at the end
of player C's turn, you have decisions
to make. Do you want to take a more
proactive turn and drop some permanence
from your hand? If yes, then you can
choose to generous gift the oblivion
stone, forcing them to crack it before
your turn comes. If not, then you can
continue to wait and keep our options
open. The turn comes, we don't want to
commit too much because of the stone,
but we want a blocker, so we drop one
that we don't mind losing too much. say
a grateful apparition, just a blocker in
case the dragon player decides to come
at us. Now we pass the turn, still
holding on to the generous gift. Player
A untaps and puts an Atsushi, the
Blazing Sky onto the stack. Good play.
This can continue to pressure the board
and isn't the worst card to lose to the
board wipe. Player B passes priority.
Now you can choose to generous gift the
Dragon Tempest and minimize damage. I
mean, who knows what they'll target and
swing at with the haste. Fine choice,
but let's say you don't do that. Dragon
Tempest triggers and three damage is
pointed at you. It seems like they're
trying to appease the artifact player to
keep the Oblivion Stone on hold for
another turn. Reasonable. And as they
declare combat, you again can choose to
destroy the oblivion stone, making it
now or never for player B, or save it
for the dragon coming at you, or do
nothing again. And I think we've seen
enough. Thanks to the instant speed
option, we had about 15 more decisions
to make. Now, if we think of each good
decision we make in a game as adding to
our chance of winning and each poor
decision detracting from it, here we can
visualize the difference between instant
speed and sorcery speed. These decisions
may range from terrible to gamewinning,
but many are probably better than
killing the wrathful red dragon in the
beginning. In commuter, time is money.
Taking your time and finding the best
window to fire off something will not
only increase our chance of winning, but
also makes us better players in the long
run. With sorcery speed, you lose all of
that and can oftenimes make plays that
hurt you more than it helps. Now, how
does this translate to board wipes? Very
well. Almost everything said above
applies to Wrath of God versus route,
except the difference in impact between
a welltimed wipe and a poorly timed one
is even bigger. A cleverly placed route
can easily win games. And this is why I
have final showdown in the highest tier
of commander board wipes alongside
Farewell. And despite being 25 years
old, route is just one tier beneath
those two. For me, the word instant is
just worth a lot of mana. I'm not sure
how much exactly, but personally, I
would play a three mana generous gift
over a one mana vindicate in most decks.
Although, I should also mention that
being overly reactive can definitely
cost you the game. I know because I
often find myself going a little bit too
far being reactive. The further you pull
a rubber band, the harder it will hit,
but it can also snap back at you if you
go too far. Finding your sweet spot
between proactive and reactive is also
something quite interesting to explore.
And as far as I know, most other popular
TCG games don't have this kind of depth.
Instants are magic. That's all. Thank
you for watching my video. If you enjoy
this kind of content, please like,
subscribe, and share your thoughts. Did
I cook or did I burn down the kitchen?
See you in the next video.